Neuronale Netze sind eine leistungsstarke Klasse von Machine-Learning-Algorithmen
und sie gibt es in vielen Varianten
Es ist unmöglich, neuronalen Netzen in einem Einführungsvideo
angemessen gerecht zu werden
Deshalb werden wir hier nur einige wichtige Komponenten
eines neuronalen Netzes und den grundlegenden Ablauf vorstellen
damit wir verstehen können, wie Quantencomputing dazu beitragen kann
Ein neuronales Netz ist ein verbundener Graph aus Neuronen
Ein Neuron ist im Grunde nur ein Ding, das eine Zahl speichert
und diese Zahl wird oft als Aktivierung bezeichnet – wie stark
das Neuron an oder aus ist
Die Neuronen sind in Schichten angeordnet
Die erste Schicht ist die Eingabeschicht
und die letzte ist die Ausgabeschicht
Dazwischen gibt es Verarbeitungsschichten, die man
verborgene Schichten nennt. Die Aktivierung der
Eingabeschicht wird direkt aus den zu analysierenden Daten geladen
zum Beispiel die Pixelhelligkeit in einem Bild
Die Aktivierungen der nächsten verborgenen Schicht werden
von den Neuronen der Eingabeschicht bestimmt
und durch Gewichte, die durch die Linien symbolisiert werden, die alle Neuronen
der Eingabeschicht mit allen Neuronen der
nächsten Schicht verbinden. Anders gesagt bestimmen wir die Aktivierung
eines Neurons in der verborgenen Schicht
durch eine gewichtete Summe aller
Eingabeaktivierungen. Wir können
außerdem einen Bias hinzufügen – eine Verschiebung
Vielleicht wollen wir ein Neuron
in der verborgenen Schicht nicht aktivieren, wenn die gewichtete Summe einfach
positiv ist, sondern erst wenn sie einen bestimmten Schwellenwert überschreitet
Danach wendet man oft eine komplizierte Funktion an, um eine Aktivierung
zwischen null und eins zu erhalten, zum Beispiel einen hyperbolischen Tangens
oder manchmal auch eine
gleichgerichtete lineare Einheit. Darüber musst du dir
jetzt keine großen Gedanken machen. Das
Einzige, was hier bei diesen Funktionen wichtig ist,
ist dass sie nichtlinear sind
sodass das Netzwerk als Ganzes sowohl lineare
als auch nichtlineare Komponenten enthält
Die gleiche gewichtete Summe von Aktivierungen – diesmal
ausgehend von den Aktivierungen der
ersten verborgenen Schicht und den neuen Gewichten –
setzt sich bis zur nächsten verborgenen Schicht fort
Das geht so weiter bis zur letzten Schicht, der Ausgabeschicht
Die Ausgabeschicht hat Neuronen, die den
Kategorien entsprechen, und die Aktivierungen zeigen uns
wie sicher das Netzwerk bei der Klassifizierung ist
Die Ausgabekategorien bei einer Bildanalyse könnten also
Hund, Katze, Hamster und so weiter sein
Eine Aktivierung von 0,95 beim
Hund-Neuron würde bedeuten, dass das Netzwerk sehr sicher ist,
dass das Bild einen Hund zeigt. Du könntest dein neuronales Netz
mit zufälligen Gewichten starten
und Biases, oder von einer bekannten vernünftigen Startkonfiguration aus
Aber dann geht es darum zu überprüfen,
wie gut dein neuronales Netz klassifiziert
und es zu verbessern. Wir verwenden eine Kostenfunktion, um zu beschreiben
wie stark unser neuronales Netz von der
richtigen Klassifizierung abweicht. Dabei wird die
Differenz zwischen dem tatsächlichen Wert eines Bildes berechnet
– zum Beispiel ein Wert von eins beim Neuron
für Hund und null bei allen anderen Ausgabeneuronen –
und den vorhergesagten Werten
Wir summieren über alle Kategorien
und erfassen so nicht nur, ob die richtige Kategorie am stärksten
aktiviert wurde, sondern wir können
auch verfolgen, ob falsche Aktivierungen reduziert werden
Dann summieren wir über alle Beispiele in unserem Trainingsset
und erhalten so die Kosten. Anschließend
variieren wir die Parameter wie die Gewichte in jeder Schicht
zwischen allen Neuronen und die Biases aller Neuronen
Klassische Optimierungsverfahren werden verwendet
um ein lokales Minimum in der Kostenfunktion zu finden
Wenn nichts getan wird, um die Komplexität davon zu reduzieren,
kannst du dir vorstellen, was für ein
astronomischer Parameterraum sich hier auftut
Stell dir ein neuronales Netz vor, das Bilder mit
gerade mal tausend Pixeln analysiert. Dieses Netz hätte tausend
Eingabeneuronen, nur eine einzige verborgene Schicht
und eine binäre Ausgabe wie Katze oder Hund
Das ist der denkbar einfachste Fall
und entspricht trotzdem tausend mal tausend
also einer Million Gewichte zwischen Eingabe- und verborgener Schicht
und weitere zweitausend zwischen der
verborgenen und der Ausgabeschicht
dazu möglicherweise noch tausend oder
so Biases. Dieses einfache neuronale Netz würde also
weit über eine Million Parameter umfassen. Fairerweise muss man sagen,
dass moderne Algorithmen normalerweise Vereinfachungen vornehmen
bei klassischen neuronalen Netzen
und es ganze Forschungsfelder gibt, die sich damit beschäftigen, diese Minimierung
möglich und sogar effizient zu machen
Aber die Tatsache bleibt, dass es sich um ein sehr
hochdimensionales Problem handelt
und das Training eines neuronalen Netzes
sehr zeitaufwendig sein kann
und teuer. Ein quantenneuronales Netz, kurz QNN,
funktioniert, indem zuerst die Eingabedaten geladen werden
und dann quantum circuits angewendet werden
die den Gewichten zwischen den Schichten entsprechen
und schließlich eine Messschicht folgt
Ein paar wichtige Punkte dazu: Die Daten-
ladung und die Gewichtungen sind lineare Operationen
aber die Messungen sind nichtlinear
Wie bei klassischen neuronalen Netzen haben wir also
sowohl lineare als auch nichtlineare Komponenten
Außerdem haben die Gewichts-circuits
weiterhin variationelle Parameter
es muss also nach wie vor eine klassische Minimierung durchgeführt werden
Natürlich haben wir hier nur an der Oberfläche quantenneuronaler
Netze gekratzt. Wir hoffen aber, dass du mehr über die Anwendungen
von quantenneuronalen Netzen
und anderen Quantum-Machine-Learning-Anwendungen lernst
mit IBM Quantum